I know you're armed
to the teeth.
I'm saying though,
what if we flip it
and now you have a bandolier
of throwing harmonicas.
I do.
Which you can play them
kind of like...
Wait you already have those?
Well, you can throw them.
Yeah. The key is like,
here's a harmonica,
see now, if you look
at the front of it,
it's kinda almost like a blade,
these are the corner,
that's the business end
right there, you just wanna
(swish)
give it a nice
little flat throw.
What if you just ended me
right now,
just right between the eyes.
He goes,
“And let me tell you something,
I'm razor precise
with this thing.”
Eh, I used to be.
And I owe Jay
something from '09.
We went to the documentary,
'Swiped',
We ain't though it yet.
Yeah, we ain't through it.
It's gonna be a two-parter.
But we're having fun with it.
Fo sho.
Turns out a lot longer
than we thought we were.
Were you trying to be popular?
I was desperately trying
to not be seen in eighth grade
and you're saying
all camera ready.
I was trying to be liked
by everybody.
They are all camera ready.
But I wasn't like...
I just hoped everyone liked me
and then my friends were kinda
like the bad kids
so I just didn't want
to get bullied by them.
I just think there was a thing,
a part of growing up that would,
people went too far
with everything obviously.
There was gluttony
in everything, but I mean,
bullying in the loosest usage
of the term
just sort of regulated things.
Well I tell yeah what didn't.
It also drove me
towards passions.
Like if everybody...
If you're a fat kid I don't know
if it's important for everybody
to go it doesn't matter,
you're beauti-,
you're an amazing person.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, but also for your health,
you should probably not be fat.
Christine brought that up with
the plus size model industry
where they're like praising
these women that are,
you said,
dangerously overweight.
Yeah.
They are moderately hot pigs.
Every one of 'em.
You said what, Christine?
I saw an ad the other day
that got me really upset.
I think it'd be like putting
an anorexic woman up
as a model and saying,
"This is beautiful."
No, this is a sickness,
this person needs help.
Yeah.
You know, or a drug addict,
like, it's crazy.
Yeah, but you also don't,
I mean, with an anorexic girl
you are like sad and bummed out,
but with like a really heavy
girl you're probably like,
"God damn that food though."
I see, now you know
what she really needs?
A little shot in the chops.
I mean what was ...
Oh that's when everybody goes,
"Obese girl?
You know what she needs?
"A little boobettes”
I like- Popper just steps
in and he goes,
"I know how to heckle anyone."
Dude, that's one of
the funniest things ever.
I thought about that twenty
minutes after him leaving,
I was still laughing at that.
Any female, he goes,
"You can heckle..."
You can heckle
Florence, watch.
"Oh my little..."
You're fat!
Yeah.
When I hear that buzzing
in my noise,
it's a bully
calling me fat!
We never really went in
to that cause John walked in.
No, there was so much...
Yeah, this ad upset me.
That ad.
Do you have... ew.
Yeah, that's dangerous.
It's dangerous.
It's absolutely dangerous,
and it's somebody promoting,
sickness is beauty.
I wanna see a pillow case
full of dimes.
Can you take me to the bank?
And you're like ," Ah man..."
Is she trying to find
a Coinstar machine
to get rid of all that?
It's an ad for clothes.
It's like a clump suit.
It's zero zero to forty,
which is fine,
it's not like women
that are size forty
shouldn't have clothes to buy,
it's just a weird thing
to normalize.
Her cankles are the thinnest
thing on her body.
But yours, yeah, you're saying
they show this
and they're like,"
Hey, this is..."
They should pose that with like,
"Hey do you need help?
Do you have a food addiction?
Like call this number."
It shouldn't be modeled as like,
you know...
Yes bitch. Be big. Be bold. Be.
Have tingly feelings
in your arms.
Yeah, diabetes.
Yeah girl, get the bottoms
of those feet round.
Heart failure... Sexy.
Do you like having strokes
in your thirties?
Then be big you bad bitch.
Do you sweat butter?
Then you'll love it.
Do you have memory loss
cause your heart is over working
and you flash
and you pass out?
Be bad you big bitch.
Do you like chocolate so much
you don't give a shit
about the right side
of your face?
Yeah. Have you woke up
driving a car?
Be big and beautiful.
Are your utensils
not big enough?
Does your piss smell
like a bag of sugar?
Are you in 24-7 ketosis?
You're right, dude!
It's like there is a point,
right?
This is fucked up!
It's sick!
It's all just like
everybody is ...
It's like the way booze,
like beer commercials
eventually in the nineties
had to start being like,
"Please drink responsibly."
Yeah, I was just
hot chicks and ...
Have you ever thought, "Why
don't they make socks wider?"
Do you find sweat pants
suffocating?
Be big, you bad bitch. You big,
beautiful, bad bitch.
Did you Christopher a dog?
Because you didn't realize that
your bichon frise was on the
couch?
Did your niece ...
Are your cats in your folds?
Did you find a remote in a fold?
Be big, be beautiful.
Did your niece run out of thread
trying to make you
a friendship necklace?
Yeah. But it is man, it's like
the way the beer commercials
were back
in the eighties, like,
"Spuds McKenzie!
Even the dog gets drunk!"
And then in the nineties
they are like,
"Please drink responsibly,
turns out this shit
just rots your liver."
Don't get the dog drunk.
Stop feeding alcohol
to party animals.
There is no such things
as a party animal.
All doing Jagermeister?
They can't process alcohol
the way we can.
When Jagermeister called me
on that tour to say,
"No jokes about
drinking irresponsibly,
or anything sexual
and alcohol related."
That's how Guinness was
when I worked for Guinness.
I can do sex jokes,
but if I go...
if I even went, "She came over,
we had a few drinks... "
Like just something like that,
they are like no no no.
Yeah they did a thing where...
You can fuck this girl
in this joke all you like
but do not give her alcohol.
You do it, she better
be stone sober.
You better enjoy
the ride of Jager,
but she better be stone sober.
I'm like, "What? Do these things
go together a lot?"
Why, have you found too much
alcohol and sex
to be problematic?
We straddle a billion dollar
fine line.
It's been a thing.
It's been a problem, but we
can't, but drink responsibly!
Cinco de Mayo!
It was weird to work
for a large alcohol company,
cause they were like,
“Here's what you can
and can not say.
Like, you can not say this
or you will lose your job.”
And I wasn't trying to go
back to waiting tables.
I know but it's like
only their one thing.
You're like, “Can I draw
a picture of Muhammad?”
And they're like,
"Yeah, that's fine, sure."
Yeah, oh absolutely,
do you want to like, fuck it?
You should probably fuck it.
A bunch of people
are probably like,
"I don't think I want
to do that at all."
And they go
Draw Muhammad,
squeezing tits and just fuck it.
Fuck it. Make him have
a big old dick and big titties.
And you like, "Okay, can I say
like I've had too many,
I had so many Guinness
he looked... "
Do not say that.
Do not say you
drank enough Guinness
to fuck the cartoon trans ...
How about I drank enough
Guinness to draw Muhammad,
yeah still, no.
No. Sorry.
It has to be a sober act.
Sorry dude.
I would never do that sober.
When you're drinking Guinness,
you just better be in a nice,
fog covered field in a wagon.
In an itchy sweater
with two of your Irish friends.
Laughing and drinking.
Ah dude. It's so funny
to see who's like,
cause there's people
that are like, into Guinness.
And I was like
Guinness ambassador.
Can you look up a list
of Guinness myths?
There's so many great ones.
They say there is
fish gel in it.
They said that like,
I always heard that there's meat
in the bottom of the barrels.
There ain't no meat.
It's rats in the barrel,
Hell yeah.
... that make it to be
a certain way.
When I met Furgo Murray,
the Brewmaster of Guinness,
and it was quite a time...
He was covered in rats
like a Tori Amos video.
He was all rats in a mans suit.
What if I told yeah that
they came together like Voltron?
He was made of seven
hundred rats.
Fun fascinating fact.
That's actually
the new Guinness point.
The old point.
These are the myths?
Yeah, but they're not...
Guinness is good for you,
well, it's alcohol.
Guinness is black. I knew that.
It's not actually. It's amber.
I knew it wasn't black.
Yeah dude, it was pretty crazy.
I was more for like,
"Guinness cures cancer.",
or something like that.
Aw, no. It's funny see
all their, you know,
we were talking
about commercials.
This is what led us to here, but
all the old commercials ones.
Look up,
"Old Guinness Commercials."
Cause they are like, "Guinness
gives you strength." That's how
they marketed it.
They are like, "Did you have
a long day at work?
Drink a couple Guinness."
The Irish work force
has alcoholism out of control.
I'm not stupid to think,
wasn't there like ads
for cigarettes
saying there are benefits
for you?
Yeah, back in the thirties
and forties and shit.
Mm-hmm.
They said smoking... Look it up!
It's what Beau said.
Like finding out
your therapist has a Twitter.
You start hacking up
and coughing
and having a lot of stuff
pretty few months into smoking.
Did anyone ever make an ad for
it months into it that was like,
"Oh guys, you know what, like
I don't know if good for you
but it's not feeling good."
Look at the print ads.
Oh, when you start smoking,
you're like...
Well, I'm saying.
How many months in
before you're like, "Whew.
I actually am feeling smoking."
Not many.
And so to have commercials
at all that are like,
"This is good for you."
It goes, "No.
If you're smoking
you already know this sucks."
Within five years of smoking.
No matter how many
commercials are on.
You feel it when you breathe.
And you go,
"It's a problem now."
But, was this the mind frame
different, where they're like,
"It's not a problem.
That's actually strength.
Those are strength wheezes."
See look.
There it is,
Guinness for strength.
So just drink this
and get strong. There's uh ...
If you drink enough of it
you think you can lift
anything though.
Christine, can you look up
which country,
I believe it might be
in Bermuda or something,
where there is a myth where if
you drink Guinness extra stout,
it's good for your potency,
for your cum.
Like make a shot on the nuts
and a pint of Guinness
will make any load
bear you a strong boy.
If you drink enough
you'll cum Guinness.
I go, "Alright now,
I'm gonna drink this Guinness,
and you just smack me
in the nuts. Ready. Go."
I'll tell ya why I hate it.
I don't like any beer
that's not carbonated.
I don't even
understand it.
Oh what, you mean
that swamp water
that they had me drinking
for two years?
I don't understand, uh...
No, it was actually delicious.
I enjoyed it.
Guinness?
Dude, I enjoy. I like Guinness.
So I was fine with it.
There did get a point
where I didn't like it.
Do you like it to?
It's like a meal.
I didn't like it.
It's flat!
I was drinking three a night,
three shows a night.
Yeah.
So that's nine Guinness.
Sure.
And then it was going out
drinking with the crew
afterwards.
Guinness. More Guinness.
Uh, no dude.
I would sneak Bud heavies.
Really?
Yeah. I got caught
by my boss at Guinness.
Like a Budweiser,
original.
Oh.
I went to the bar at the hotel
in Ireland,
when we were there
drinking in Dublin,
and I went down and had a shot
of Jack Daniels and Budweiser
and the guy from Guinness
came out
and was like,
“Oh, what are you doing?”
I was like, “Ha ha, I was just
seeing how shitty it is.”
It's like, “I have to check
and see
if the other one sucks
as much as I remember.”
Oh this is gross-ass rice beer
and then the whole time
I was like,
“This is so sweet
and delicious.”
Like a gerbil
at a water thing.
You just take
a little bit of it,
he goes “You have a shot.”
And he goes, “Aw, disgusting.
It's just terrible.
I can't even believe
I'm doing it.”
Mm, oh my God,
I'm punishing myself.
I'm so sadomasochistic.
And each time you take a little
bit more of the shot.
"Oh God, it's so gross.
I'm not savoring it or anything.
I'm relishing
in how gross it is."
When I tried quitting
drinking one time,
and I got like five weeks,
and I felt really good about it.
And this was before
I read the book,
The Easy Way to Quit Drinking.
It was like, I felt really great
about it and then they are like,
"Hey, Guinness wants you
to do ten more cities."
And you know that point, where
you're making money off comedy,
but if you don't have
another side job it's hard.
It's like really hard.
So I was at that point
where I was headlining,
not making a lot of money
at all on the weekends,
and then trying
to do this thing.
I was like, alright,
I'll do ten more cities,
but I'll try not to drink.
For some reason I thought
I didn't have to drink.
I was like...
Gonna put some ice tea
in my cup.
No, just do a fake sip.
Just like take it and be like...
The first night we're in Boston
I do the three shows...
You shotgun it?
Dude, this is how much I just
completely jump back in
and I'm so wishy-washy.
We go out, the president
of Guinness shows up,
this Irish guy
who just took over.
And he's like, “I'd like
to have a pint with ya.
Let's go out and talk.”
We're just at this bar
and he puts down two beers
and I'm like,
well I have to drink this beer,
cause this dudes in front of me.
So I drink the beer
and then I'm like,
“Let's have another one.
Can we have another one?”,
and then I'm like,
“Do you want to do a shot?”,
and he's like,
“I would love to do a shot!"
I go out and get fucking
hammered with this guy,
like fucking hammered.
I hadn't drank in five weeks
and I was like,
"Do you got a pack of cigarettes
on you? What's up dude?”
I was like,
“You fucking tiny Mick!",
by the end of it.
I go, "This sausage finger fuck
is my new best friend."
I go, "He runs Guinness anyways.
I'm the ambassador.
Suck my dick!"
Dude, it became...
I started blacking out,
I'm gonna be at the DC
Draft House this weekend.
I can't go to DC
without thinking about
when we did the Guinness shows.
I got blackout drunk
and just smoked cigarettes
in my hotel room,
like it was the seventies.
And then a week later
I called the hotel
and I did my best official
white guy voice.
There's an odd charge
from my card.
Yeah! I called, I go,
“There's a strange charge.”,
and all I did was say this.
The guy goes,
“it was a cleaning fee.
I think you smoked
in your room.”
I go, “That's funny,
I don't smoke.”
And he goes,
“Oh, that's weird.”
It got put back
on my credit card.
It's a catch 22, they always
have to give it back.
They always have
to give it back.
If you call them out like,
“I didn't smoke in my room.
Be like...”
Yeah, now you're calling me
a smoker.
You're saying I'm a smoker.
You're gonna call me a smoker.
How dare you.
Hang on, cause you're stressing
me the fuck out, hang on...
Let me get a cigarette,
I mean, I don't even smoke.
Um...
Yeah, it was bad.
You call me a smoker,
right to my ears.
And then I was taking that
drinking energy on the road
when I was doing comedy.
Danny Suds Mackenzie?
Dude. Hell yeah.
Duffman. That's what
all my friends called me.
Just a fucking knapsack full
of Hawaiian shirts and jams.
And I go, "Dude,
you ready to party?
All you need is a Miller Lite."
You know the best thing
about Hawaiian shirts?
It's day gear
and sleep gear.
Yeah, it's pajama-jams
and day-jams. It was a...
You can't see puke
on a weird landscaped shirt.
Guinness is owned by
this company named Diageo,
and they are like
a major alcohol company.
They own Johnny Walker,
Jose Cuervo, Smirnoff.
They own most major brands.
They have an office
over on 45th and 5th,
and if you are an employee
they have a full bar.
Lou, don't jizz
in your pants.
You can walk in and you are not
allowed to tip the bartenders.
Do they need an engineer?
And you can drink
whatever you want.
So, I would be like...
Always?
If you are an employee
of Diageo,
you can go have a drink
at the bar when you want.
Of anything.
So I just went and had a Johnny
Walker Blue,
like at the bar.
Just like, "Alright."
And by the way it was when
I was doing a Monday night.
Christine
just creamed her jeans.
Yeah! But it was a Monday night
when I was doing a show
at Caroline's,
and I showed up drunk
to Caroline's.
I was like,
"What time am I on?"
And the are like, "It's nine.
How are you this drunk?"
I was like, "I went by Diageo
at like five o'clock."
And you don't tip.
You just sit there.
The most awkward time
of my life was,
and you'll know this
as a cigarette smoker,
was leaving to go smoke
a cigarette
and then trying
to get back in
without looking like
a raging alcoholic.
Cause I left and I was like,
“Alright bye everybody!”
And then I'm just downstairs,
and I'm like,
“I'm gonna go back up and
fucking have a Guinness Black
and another shot of...”
And then trying to get
back in like,
This fucking rules!
“Yeah, is Christine here?”
That was the girl I knew
that worked there. Kristen.
And I was like,
"Can I talk to Kristen?"
Do you? She's totally cool.
"Let me back in."
Trying to grab the door...
"Just let me back in."
Yeah, she tries to close it
but you put you
your foot back in.
"No no, just wait. I'm saying
her name right. Kristen?"
"Did I say something mean
to Andy the bartender
I thought we were friends.
I told him I was gonna smoke,
he said it's be cool."
I think I left my wallet inside.
Do you mind if I smoke
in the stairwell?
What?
Give me one thing!
Give me one thing?
Just do one thing for me!
Just do one of the things
I'm asking!
Why won't you do
one of the things for me?
I'm meeting you halfway.
The most pathetic weekends
of my life
were where I was on the road
and I was like,
“I'm not drinking this weekend”"
And then you're talking
like that and they're like,
“You have media in four hours.”
And you're like “ ... your
media.”
You're the one who's
fucking the media up.
Whatever. I'm gonna wake up
fresh as a daisy.
Then you wake up and everything
is sideways until ...
I'm gonna go puke this, okay?
I wanna love you and I wanna
move to Syracuse
and be with you.
I think we should be together.
Let's just take over this
little radio station
together me and you,
he goes,
"Ah, sorry, our guest
seems to be a little weird.
This is Woody
and The Scooch on so..."
And he goes, "Why don't you guys
just turn these microphones off
and lets just be together."
Can we talk like we did
when I walked in?
Ah, we're getting a little
uncomfortable here.
Fifth caller is gonna get
free tickets to Dan's show.
He goes,
"I don't even wanna do a show.
I wanna get a little cottage
with you two."
Can I show you me?
Coming back with the five,
tickets for Dan Soder.
He's gonna be
at The Funny Bone.
Don't know what his acts about.
You've seen him on Geico
and he's a little out
of it right now.
Can I show you me? What is that?
Can I show you. Me?
I wanna show you.
I wanna be with you though.